[Música]
la esclavitud el trato a seres humanos
como propiedad privada despojados de
derechos adoptó muchas formas en todo el
mundo pero una institución se destaca
por su escala mundial y su legado el
comercio transatlántico de esclavos que
ocurrió desde fines de siglo 15 hasta
mediados del siglo 19 en tres
continentes y llevó a la fuerza a más de
10 millones de africanos a América su
impacto no solo afectó a los esclavos y
sus descendientes sino también a las
economías e historias de grandes
regiones del mundo el contacto entre
Europa y África a través del
Mediterráneo existía hacía siglos pero
el comercio Atlántico de esclavos
comenzó a fines de siglo 15 con el
asentamiento de colonias portuguesas en
África occidental y las españolas en
América
en las nuevas colonias se cultivaban
caña de azúcar tabaco y algodón cultivos
laboriosos y no había suficientes
colonos o sirvientes para cultivar todas
esas nuevas tierras se esclavizó a los
nativos americanos pero muchos murieron
por enfermedades mientras que otros
resistían para satisfacer la demanda de
mano de obra los europeos miraron hacia
África en África ya existía la
esclavitud una práctica que adoptaba
muchas formas algunos esclavos eran
sirvientes por plazos limitados y podían
comprar su libertad
en algunas sociedades los esclavos
podían ser parte de la familia de su amo
poseían tierras e incluso ocupaban
cargos de poder pero cuando los blancos
llegaron ofreciendo mercaderías armas y
ron a cambio de esclavos Los Reyes y
comerciantes africanos dudaron poco
ellos veían a los que vendían no como
compatriotas africanos sino como
delincuentes deudores o prisioneros de
guerra de tribus rivales al venderlos
Los Reyes enriquecieron sus reinos Y los
fortalecieron los reinos africanos
prosperaron con la trata de esclavos
pero la demanda europea creó una intensa
competencia
la esclavitud reemplazó otra sentencias
criminales y la captura de esclavos se
convirtió en una causa de guerra en
lugar de su resultado para defenderse de
la captura de esclavos los reinos
necesitaron armas europeas que compraron
con esclavos el comercio de esclavos se
había convertido en una carrera
armamentística que afectó a las
sociedades y economías en todo el
continente en cuanto a los esclavos se
enfrentaron a una brutalidad
inimaginable eran llevados a fuertes en
la costa afeitados para evitar los
piojos y marcados y luego eran cargados
en barcos con rumbo a América un 20% de
ellos nunca volvería a ver Tierra Firme
la mayoría de los capitanes atestaban
sus buques abarrotando sus bodegas de
hombres
muchos morían por enfermedades por falta
de higiene y otros serán arrojados por
la borda por estar enfermos o como
método disciplinario El capitán
aseguraba sus ganancias al cortar las
orejas de los Esclavos como prueba de
compra
algunos esclavos tomaron riendas en el
asunto muchos en África nunca habían
visto un hombre blanco y pensaron que
eran caníbales ya que se llevaban gente
y regresaban por más por miedo a ser
devorados o para evitar más sufrimiento
muchos se suicidaban o se dejaban morir
de hambre convencidos de que después de
la muerte sus almas regresarían a casa
los que sobrevivieron fueron
deshumanizados y tratados como mercancía
las mujeres y los niños Se mantenían
encubierta y eran abusados por la
tripulación mientras que a los hombres
se les hacía bailar para mantener los
ejercitados y contener las rebeliones
lo que pasó con los africanos en el
nuevo mundo y como el legado de la
esclavitud aún afecta a sus
descendientes es bien conocido
pero se habla poco del efecto que tuvo
la trata de esclavos En el futuro de
África
no solo el continente perdió millones de
habitantes sanos sino que al ser hombres
la mayoría de los esclavizados el efecto
demográfico a largo plazo fue aún mayor
los reinos africanos cuyas economías
dependían de la trata de esclavos
colapsaron cuando esta fue prohibida en
América y Europa lo cual favoreció la
conquista y la colonización
además la mayor competencia y la
afluencia de armas europeas avivaron la
guerra y la inestabilidad que continúan
hasta hoy
el comercio Atlántico de esclavos
también contribuyó al racismo
la esclavitud africana se entendió como
el resultado de un castigo o la guerra
entre tribus pero los europeos que
predicaban una religión universal y que
habían proscrito la esclavitud de
cristianos necesitaron una justificación
para una práctica tan contraria a sus
ideales de igualdad
por ello afirmaban que los africanos
eran biológicamente inferiores y
pusieron mucho empeño en justificar esta
teoría
así la esclavitud en Europa y América
adquirió un fundamento racial e
imposibilitó que los esclavos y sus
descendientes pudieran alcanzar un
estatus equitativo por todo esto el
comercio transatlántico de esclavos fue
una injusticia inmensa cuyo impacto
persiste mucho después de su abolición
comprender la historia nos da la
oportunidad de aprender del pasado para
no repetirlo con este video Explore las
circunstancias que permitieron a Hitler
alcanzar el poder en un país democrático
o con este video profundice en el pánico
de la Guerra Fría conocido como la
crisis de misiles en